c'est vraiment une adhésion aux valeurs
une valeur de tolérance des valeurs
d'humanisme toutes ces valeurs là dans
lesquelles je me reconnais m'ont fait
adhérer au
[Musique]
modèle bonjour je suis Francette j'ai 55
ans je suis père de deux enfants et
j'habite voisin de bretonneis dans les
Yvelines où j'occupe les fonctions de
mère adjoint j'ai tout d'abord suivi une
formation comptable et financière qui
m'a permis d'obtenir un certain nombre
de postes dans les différentes PME au
niveau responsable financier j'ai
ensuite créé ma propre entreprise de
location de véhicule qui a duré pendant
à peu près 4 ans que j'ai revendu
ensuite puis j'ai rejoint un groupe
international le groupe Transdev pendant
une douzaine d'années où j'ai occupé
d'autres fonction financière de
responsabilité financière j'ai ensuite
rejoint le modem en tant que responsable
financier mon engagement politique dans
la vie de la cité plutôt en toute
généralité est assez ancien je me suis
intéressé au MoDem à partir de 2012
principalement j'ai adhéré en 2014 j'ai
intégré le Conseil national en 2021 j'ai
été trésorier des ivelides en 2022 j'ai
ensuite euh par mes actions également au
sein de la commune était tête de liste
pour les municipales et j'ai égal donc
été élu avec Madame le Maire pour être
maire adjoint ce que j'aime c'est
vraiment euh pouvoir être au contact ma
délégation me le permet puisque je suis
au niveau de la démocratie locale donc
j'ai vraiment un contact avec les
citoyens au sein des conseils de
quartier je suis également en charge des
jumelages et là toute mon envie
européenne s'y reconnaît c'est vraiment
une adhésion au valeurs une valeur de
tolérance des valeurs d'humanisme je
suis profondément européen je crois
vraiment en l'amitié entre les peuples
entre tous nos peuples européens toutes
ces valeurs là dans lesquelles je me
reconnais m'ont fait adhérer au
model y